hi everyone i'm rupak shivakodi an
assistant professor of epidemiology at
columbia university and the title of my
talk today is got microbiota and
maternal infant populations with hiv
so here's a brief outline for today's
talk we will start with the basic
overview of the gut microbiome
then we'll talk about gut microbiota in
pregnancy how that is different and then
the temporal dynamics of the microbiota
within pregnancy
and then in this last part we will talk
about gut microbiota pregnancy gut
microbiota and how it is impacted by hiv
status as well as how
it impacts
health outcomes such as birth outcomes
and infant growth
as well as its relationship with
inflammation so this last part
there's limited data on this
as a result i'll present an ongoing
study
and
provide some preliminary data related to
that
so we'll start with the overview of the
gut microbiome
as again as a basic overview
humans have 10 trillion human cells
and 20 000 human genes
in contrast a human has around 100
trillion bacterial cells and 2 to 20
million bacterial genes so you can see
that the
cells is about
10 times more bacterial cells than human
cells and then at the gene level it's
about a hundred to a thousand fold
higher bacterial genes compared to human
genes
there are some newer estimates that
suggest that instead of 1 to 10 the
ratio is a little bit closer to one to
one
but regardless i know we have a lot of
bacterial cells and bacterial genes
within us
as a definition
microbiota and microbiome are often used
interchangeably
but they do have different meanings so
microbiota is a particular microbe
community so that's what we're talking
about when we say microbiota
that is residing in and on the human
body so this is really focused on the
composition
this includes bacteria viruses
archaea and micro eukaryotes and then
microbiome in contrast is not just the
microbes but also the genes of the human
microbiota so this is
looking at both composition as well as
the function so composition again is
who's there and then function is what
are they doing
and let's let's uh look through this and
this
as an example this is from the human
microbiome project
and published in 2013 uh at the top
is a graph of the microbiota so this is
just the composition
and
which you can't see here but these in a
different columns and different
different columns here on the x-axis are
really different individuals
and what we have here is bacteria from
the different phyla so what you can see
here is example for example for this
person
it's mostly blue right so it's mostly
their microbiome is mostly from the
phyllo bacteria deities
in contrast here this person has more
green
at this end and so
they're mostly from the firmicutes
violet so what you can see here is if
you look at individuals different
individuals there's variability
so for some individuals
it's dominated by bacterial adidas while
in other individuals there's more
firmicutes
in addition some of these other bacteria
so it is dominated for the most part by
firmicutes and bacteria deities at the
phyla level but there are other bacteria
such as proteobacteria look at the
yellow you can see that in some
individuals it's almost non-existent and
while in other individuals it almost
makes up about half of
half of their microbiota so there is
inter individual
variation in the composition but if you
look at the function these are the same
individuals in the bottom graph and then
these are the different functions you
can see that despite the differences in
composition the functions are much more
conserved they seem pretty similar
across individuals
and now to extend that further from the
same
paper
you can see that you know what we just
saw was in the stool sample
but if you look at these other other
microbiota sites for example a lot of
these are the oral microbiota you can
again see there is differences in the
composition but the function
seems much more much more conserved
so really the conclusion from from this
part is despite compositional
differences among healthy individuals
the core metabolic and functional
pathways seem relatively stable and the
key here is this is this is what we see
in healthy individuals this is not to
say that in diseased individuals or
individuals at different life stages
might have the same
have have the same profile there there
could be differences in both the
function and the composition there
uh so
let's let's focus on the gut microbiota
so the human gi tract is the most
densely colonized anatomic site in
humans
overall the human gi tract has about one
to one
one thousand to fifteen hundred
different species that can colonize it
but any one individual carries about 150
to 160 bacterial species at a time
so you can see that there's a lot of
choices to choose from so each
individual has a unique microbiota
although each individual has a unique
microbiota as we saw earlier from that
graph
bacteria from these two phyllite
formicutes and bacteria adidas dominate
the gut and this is really when we say
when we were talking about gut
microbiota at least for for this talk
we're mostly talking about fecal samples
and which really represents the luminal
content of large intestine
and as we said around 90 percent of the
bacterial group found in humans in the
gut are from these two phyla
and then most bacteria in the bacterial
adidas phylum belong to the class
bacterias and specifically at the genus
level in bacteroides and prevotella
and then most
species in the
firmicutes phylum belong to clostridium
clusters again you know
at the genus level they're clostridium
and eu bacterium for example
there are other phyllis such as
ectinobacteria
proteobacteria fuso bacteria uh and you
know as as i said earlier you know if
proteobacteria just one percent uh in
some individuals it did make up quite a
bit of uh much more than one percent so
so there is variability between
individuals
so now let's talk about um how gut
microbiota is is
different uh or is it different in
pregnancy
um so we'll start by one of the earlier
studies to look at this uh this was a
study that was done in europe where they
looked at the fecal
bacteria of 91 pregnant
pregnant women and they got samples uh
once each in the first trimester of
pregnancy and then the third trimester
of pregnancy
and
what they noticed was the gut microbiota
changed dramatically from trimester 1 to
trimester 3.
so the first thing they noted was there
was reduced alpha diversity there was
reduced bacterial richness
and what do we mean by alpha diversity
so just just a very
basic background on this is alpha
diversity is is based on two different
concepts
uh it's it's so the first one is
richness it's looking at how many
different organisms or species
there are in a sample
and then the second one is evenness so
it's not just how many different
organisms there are but how similar the
abundances of different organisms are so
it's both a property of richness and
evenness
and let's let's uh look at
uh illustrate this through the example
of this cartoon that's used as fruits
so in this example in the left
what you see here is you know there are
three different fruits
uh but it's mostly dominated by apples
right so it has low richness compared to
uh you know it's a relative right so low
richness compared to an example with
more fruits
and it has low evenness but evenness
because it's dominated by one one um
one fruits or you can think about you
know in the context of bacteria one one
genus or one species
in contrast uh in this example here
they're still low richness uh but
there's high evenness they're more even
it's not dominated by just one species
and then these examples here are where
there's high richness so there's a
greater number of fruits or bacteria
right but it's still dominated by
one uh one fruit so it's low evenness
but high richness and this last example
is where it's both
rich and evenness so this is an example
where
uh
this high rich and high evenness would
have the highest greatest diversity
score alpha diversity score uh compared
to
high richness and low evenness so both
of these matter at least for some
indices of alpha diversity
so
as we said you know what this is saying
is from the first trimester to the third
trimester the alpha diversity or the
richness is decreased
how about beta diversity so they also
looked at uh beta diversity and the next
slide we'll talk about what that is but
it's really there is the diversity
between mothers right so when we're
talking about alpha diversity it is
really within a sample
within a specific sample here we're
comparing two different samples so the
diversity between mothers increased from
trimester one to time trimester three so
let's look at
the concept of beta diversity very
briefly again
it is a measure of similarity between
the communities of two different samples
so how many organisms so this is a
property of two different things so how
many organisms are shared between the
two samples
and then whether the organisms shared
are present in in the same abundance so
it also has this concept of
same abundance so the higher the beta
diversity the less similar the
communities are
and then beta diversity is high in the
gut so different people have different
microbes because there's a lot of
choices to choose from as we said
earlier because so they're less similar
to each other
compared to
beta diversity in a different or
different body site for example
uh so what they saw here was there was a
vast expansion of diversity between
mothers so from trimester one
uh the trimester one mothers were more
similar to each other compared to the
trimester 3m
microbiota
and then there was an overall increase
in proteobacteria and actinobacteria in
trimester 3.
so really what these findings indicate
is that by trimester three the
microbiotas were depleted of bacterial
phylogenetic diversity this is alpha
diversity is depleted but in ways that
differ between women so that that's the
increase in
beta diversity that the second part is
referring to
uh so the study they also looked at
there were 29 different um
otus or species whose relative abundance
reliably discriminated between trimester
one and trimester three and if you're
wondering whether trimester one or
trimester three is more similar to the
non-pregnant uh
non-pregnant woman it was trimester one
so trimester one was more similar to the
non-pregnant woman
and then they also did a
transplant a fecal transplant in
germ-free mice
where they transplanted either trimester
3 from the moms these are human pregnant
moms either the trimester three fecal
samples or trimester one fecal samples
and then they looked at inflammation and
adiposity and what they saw was when you
transferred trimester three microbiota
that that increased that resulted in
greater inflammation and increased
adiposity compared to when when you
transplanted the t1 uh the trimester one
microbiota so
the conclusion of the authors or
gestational age related changes in the
microbiota that promote weight gain
suggest that you know
as as pregnancy is a unique state
um they require greater energy harvest
so the microbiota
have been
adapted to help with the greater energy
harvest needed during pregnancy to
support the growth of the mother and the
fetus so this is again uh micro
uh the composition uh related to the
function and that that we're getting at
here
there was another study that was
published in 2015
this was a case control study of 49
pregnant women and in this study instead
of just you know last study just got one
sample on trimester one and one sample
in trimester three here they instead got
weekly samples on during pregnancy and
it was not just stool samples they also
got
these additional samples that we won't
talk about today
but they had weekly samples and then
they looked at alpha diversity they
looked at beta diversity and they also
looked at
what they called instability so this is
really
also a way of looking at beta diversity
but it's looking at how the samples
differ
between the same subject sample
over time so you're looking at same
subject community sampled in consecutive
weeks
so here's the result from that study
and then you know
i won't talk about these other other
body sites other than to say you know
the message was largely similar but what
you can see is if you look at alpha
diversity beta diversity or
or instability or beta diversity
for the most part they seem pretty
stable so in the x-axis is gestational
weeks of pregnancy
so you can see that for the most part
they seem pretty stable so the stability
and the beta diversity especially you
know the p-values also support that and
then for the alpha diversity there could
be a slight decrease uh you know again
the p-value is it's not significant
but it is 0.053
so there could be a trend for decreased
alpha diversity
but the overall message is this looks
you know if you look at the stability
over week that it looks pretty stable
during this time period so how do you
bring these two different studies that
we just talked about together
and one way to think about this is that
trimester one versus trimester three
which is that first study uh there are
likely differences in the gut microbiota
and microbiome and this makes sense
there's
major differences in physiological needs
of the mom and the fetus between
trimester one which is which is uh much
more similar to the non-pregnant stage
compared to trimester three
uh but if you think about the
differences between trimester two and
trimester three there might not be as
many differences
not just the studies that we talked
about but multiple other follow-up
studies have shown minimal changes in
gut microbiota and this is not universal
but most of the studies seem to suggest
this
during the trimester two and trimester
three
uh there's still gaps in knowledge for
example uh this these two studies were
done in europe and north america um
how how might
this be different in other settings
especially resource limited settings
where the baseline microbiota is already
really different
and then what happens in the setting of
disease all right these were in healthy
healthy women what happens for example
in populations with hiv
so that's the next focus uh next part
we'll focus on that
so let's start with pregnancy gut
microbiota and hiv stats
uh why might we be interested in
studying got microbiota in hiv
so
the first part before we talk about gut
microbiota is to talk about the gut
dysfunction that happens during hiv
hiv infects cd4 t cells and a lot of the
cd4 t cells are in the gut so as a
result of hiv infection
there is impaired gut integrity
so
here is an example infection
this cartoon is not exclusive to hiv
but but a similar concept happens with
with for example other other things as
well
but let's imagine hiv infection is
happening
and as a result
uh the epithelial cells that are
normally held tight together uh become
leaky so there is microbes can now
translocate
um from the lumen into the bloodstream
and this can result in things like
monocyte activation and then ultimately
inflammation
this increased inflammation this
increased
impaired gut integrity
this increased microbial translocation
have been independently associated with
a lot of adverse outcomes for example
higher levels of these markers in hiv
have been linked to mortality increased
mortality
increased treatment outcomes and then
cardiovascular disease a lot of
different outcomes
but how about in pregnancy
so we looked at a study
trying to
look at the role of again some of the
same markers so impaired gut integrity
and inflammation
in this study we specifically looked at
again marker of
gut barrier dysfunction ifab
and then two markers of
monocyte activation
and what you see is that and this is in
a population with hiv and what we see
here is that uh higher levels of again
markers of monocyte activation and
intestinal barrier uh dysfunction are
associated with increased preterm birth
so if you have higher levels of these
markers during pregnancy
uh you're more likely to deliver a baby
that is pre-term birth
so it sounds like you know
gut dysfunction and inflammation also
plays a role in pregnancy outcomes
in hiv in populations with hiv
so how about more specifically related
to gut dysbiosis so given what we just
talked about the impact of
hiv on blood function
a related question then is is there a
difference in the microbiota profile of
pregnant woman by hiv status
because there are differences among
adults so this would be you know
extending that to a population with
pregnancy
which is a special uh stage of life uh
there there's uh different you know
physiological changes happening hormonal
changes that are happening so
it's not a guarantee that whatever is
happening in adults is also happening
during pregnancy
and then if there is uh differences in
the microbiota profile by hiv status
could these differences be contributing
to some of the adverse outcomes that you
see in maternal infant populations with
hiv
so for example as i said earlier hiv
infected
pregnant women they deliver more preterm
birth babies than uninfected women
they also have babies that are lower uh
that have that have a low birth weight
compared to women without hiv
in addition after the infants are born
uh the infants actually also have growth
deficits
for example there's more stunting uh
there is more wasting uh
underweight so uh
the infants although the infants do not
have hiv infection themselves these are
these are called hiv exposed uninfected
what this means is their moms have hiv
infection but they themselves do not
uh despite not having hiv infection they
also have growth deficits
so could the microbiome be playing a
role in this
in addition uh what's also known is what
is the temporal dynamics of the gut
microbiota during pregnancy as i said
earlier in diverse settings and is this
different by hiv status
uh
what is the relationship of gut
microbiota with gut dysfunction and
inflammation that we just talked about
and then what is the relationship of gut
microbiota with other factors for
example diet
because you could then think about
modulating the diet or directly
modulating the gut microbiota as an
intervention
to then improve some of these outcomes
such as preterm birth
so to address some of these questions we
conducted a study it was a cohort study
in india
we're calling it the prachiti cohort
study
and this has two two uh
populations within this so one is hiv
infected pregnant woman there are 92
that we enrolled and then there is hiv
uninfected pregnant women this these are
155 and the inclusion criteria is
pregnant women that are greater than 18
years of age
with gestational age between 13 to 34
weeks enrollment so either in their
second or third trimester of pregnancy
and then of note all of them will be on
antiretroviral therapy
uh and then we again recruit them in the
second trimester we follow them uh at we
have a visit at third trimester
we have visits and delivery and then we
follow them up to uh two years
postpartum as well as we follow their
infants as well
so the study design is uh
specifically related to microbiome is
that we collect stool samples in the
second trimester we collect them at the
third trimester and then at postpartum
we also collect at six months postpartum
in all of the women from from the
prachiti study
and then in addition to the moms we also
collect at six months from the infant so
these are the
heu again these are infants who do not
have hiv themselves but their moms do
and then huu these are infants who don't
who don't have hiv and their moms also
don't have hiv so it's hiv unexposed
uninfected
in addition to the stool samples we also
have data on inflammation so these are
again markers of gut integrity monocyte
activation and other markers of
inflammation
we also collected detailed uh dietary
data and then finally we collected
clinical data on birth outcomes so this
this includes
preterm birth and low birth weight and
then infant growth and again this
includes infant height
weight
so that you can
measure you know you can compare and
study the relationship of gut microbiome
with again you know
stunting wasting and then other
anthropometric measures
so really
with this design we can ask the
relationship of gut microbiome with hiv
status
as well as these other things so let's
start by talking about hiv status
so this is again preliminary data this
is from about half of our cohort a
little less than half of our cohort uh
so
we we should consider this data at this
point
preliminary uh so this is
samples from either the second or third
trimester they've been right for this
graph we only show the third trimester
data and this is looking at alpha
diversity again remember this is the
richness
within a sample and what you can see
here is that if you look at the p value
on the alpha diversity in hiv infected
versus hiv uninfected pregnant women
does not seem to be different and then
this graph is looking at beta diversity
and this is a pca pcoa plot and what you
can see here again is that
the beta diversity does not seem to
differ by hiv status so the alpha
diversity and beta diversity
it seems to be similar
however if you look at the
bacteria
the differences in the bacteria this is
at the family level that we're looking
at
what you can see here is that this is
hiv negative here and hiv positive here
what you can see here is that
at the family level at the prevotella
family uh you can see that hiv positive
pregnant women have lower levels of
prevotella and higher levels of the
violinella
again this is at the family level
uh the other differences uh don't seem
as drastic they seem more similar but
these are the two that there are some
some differences that we observe
and then here is looking at the various
different levels i know this is a busy
slide uh but just want to say you know
so this is looking at
kingdom uh phyla
class family and genus
and then this uh in the left is hiv
positive and this is uh in the right is
hiv negative
and uh we already talked about the
family in the last slide and here is the
data at the
at the genus level and again what you
can see here is if you compare the two
graphs uh there is there seems to be
more provatella in the hiv negative so
hiv positive have less prevotella and
then um
again this isn't us so easy to see but
but higher levels of megaspare uh and
again i'll just say that this is
preliminary data and uh we will have a
lot more samples and a lot more data
that will allow us to
have have a better sense of this data
and you know be able to do some
statistics as well
uh so again
we talked about now the relationship of
got microbiome with hiv status
uh so the next one is looking at stage
of pregnancy so the rest of this is uh i
will
talk about just the study design because
the data is not there yet
but
what we did here is i know so first of
all we do have
uh how does the gut microbiome differ by
the stage of pregnancy so as i said
earlier we have data in second trimester
we have data on third trimester and we
have data
at six months postpartum
in addition uh to get a better sense we
also did a sub study
where we did much more intense sampling
so this is looking at the temporal
dynamics of the gut microbiome uh in
pregnancy
so again we uh
for this sub study we co-recruited from
women that were already enrolled in the
prachiti study
uh and
we enrolled two cohorts uh so this is
hiv infected pregnant woman and hiv
uninfected pregnant women still and but
the sample size was 35 in each group
uh and again their gestational age was
uh the inclusion criteria was slightly
different so we only picked the woman
from prachiti that were enrolled
at least you know
before 24 weeks so that we could get a
more frequent sampling and we followed
them every two weeks so we recruited
them between 20 and 24 weeks and then we
followed them every two weeks until 34
weeks of
gestation so here's the design we
collected stool samples in addition we
also collected a dietary data in each of
those time points
and really the objective of this sub
study is to get a better sense at the
relationship of gestational age with
microbiome profiles so how does the
microbiome profile change with
gestational age so we could look at
things like an alpha diversity beta
diversity and stability over gestation
and then having these two different
populations will also allow us to
understand whether the temporal dynamics
changes by hiv status
and then the reason for collecting the
dietary data again is to understand the
relationship of short-term and we also
have a long-term dietary intake to
understand the relationship of
short-term versus long-term dietary
intake with microbiome profile
data from other studies suggest that
long-term might be more important
but we will confirm this in our study
and we will also understand the
relationship of diet and microbiome
because
you might then get ideas of how to
modulate the diet in order to modulate
the microbiome
so think of it thinking of it as
intervention potential uh for example
for pre-term birth
so
i'll end with the future directions
really the sequencing is it has been
completed for the full sample size we
have over 1400
samples that are that have been
sequenced now currently we're doing the
bioinformatics analysis and then really
the comparisons that will happen next in
the mothers
we will look at as we said in the full
cohort we'll look at second versus third
versus uh six months postpartum and then
um we actually also have a non-pregnant
comparison group so we can also compare
pregnant versus non-pregnant versus
postpartum and then as i said in
addition we'll have the more intense
sub-study where where we have samples
every two weeks
in addition as we said we will update
the analysis on hiv status and gut
microbiome and then again how that
differs
uh
in
how the temporal dynamic differs
uh we will study the relationship of
maternal microbiome and we also actually
have a metabolomics data in a subset
so the relationship of maternal
microbiome and metabolism during
pregnancy with birth outcomes so how
does maternal microbiome during
pregnancy impact birth outcomes such as
preterm birth and low birth weight
similarly we'll also look at how does
maternal microbiome during pregnancy
impact infant growth indices
uh so we do have that data on infants
and then finally a more analysis around
you know correlation is is looking at
relationship of microbiome with diet
inflammation and metabolism these other
analysis are a longitudinal data
analysis and this is more at one one
time point which is mostly the third
trimester
and then for the infants we can look at
how does the maternal hiv status
uh
impact the infant microbiome so this is
again the comparison between the hiv
exposed versus the hiv unexposed
infants both of which whom are
uninfected and then we can also study
the relationship of maternal and infant
microbiome so
with that i will end the lecture and
here are my acknowledgments this is our
team in
in in us in india
and then also i'd like to thank our
funding sources thank you